which one oh okay I need to focus focus
focus focus
get off me oh [ __ ] there's two of them
did nothing
all right totally click oh [ __ ] I need I
need help
oh [ __ ] she's right behind me hello it
says a little string it's gone
mio mio mio mio okay okay
this one at a time I can do it [ __ ] I
can't do it his room is too small
huh I'm screwed so screwed I never been
more screwed except that one time I got
screwed
whatever come on I'm so glad I'm so glad
I'm so that I'm the one to die I don't
wanna die I don't wanna die
get the [ __ ] out of my way I gotta have
more stuff to eat somewhere oh wait I
have a ton of herbal medicine okay it's
just a hair in the corner and then okay
let's go for him first
here we'll trip now and that way
clickety-clack yes oh [ __ ]
no yes
I hate him so much hi come on come on
come on come on my my oh my god no no
why do you go there why why why what's
way no no no no okay over here perfect
okay I'm gonna take photos of you
where's all the guy where is he where
I see you
doing get over here and then ah he was
right behind me
[ __ ] backstabber oh [ __ ] you start oh
my god oh my god oh my god I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die gonna die if they come on
come on Peter fight you can do this you
can do it you can do this
I don't want to waste all my come on
they're everywhere ah no [ __ ] way I
could do this so [ __ ] easily fit yeah
okay wait in the corner cap in the
corner yes perfect take photos of the
corner now take a picture of that
[ __ ]
oh she's okay come at me how do you like
that
[ __ ]
how do you like that fatal frame [ __ ]
you too
how does that feel
gets up oh wait the girl is still light
oh [ __ ] she is uh oh damn you're so sexy
fatal frame [ __ ] okay she's not that
yet on the guy is there huh Mike Mike
Mike Mike Mike Mike my partner so
disorienting and confusing
come at me oh yeah I should leave with
her first oh I hate her I should do it
no I didn't kill her
Oh
wait I don't wanna die I don't wanna die
I don't wanna die I'm not gonna die like
this run run run run
we're supposed to run when I say run not
walk oh my god I just need to get out
one of them it'll be a lot easier you
see I missed how is it even possible
there she is come on I hate you
ah I'm getting seriously pissed off
okay come at me dad your dad how does
that feel oh he's not that perfect oh my
god are you where are you I don't care
about you where's the girl other you are
come at me bro
uh-huh that got a do it yes now I'm
gonna take your boyfriend how does that
feel
yes yes yes the camera loves you
this your hair I don't know what what's
up with your hair let's keep it down
here and wait for him to fall
perfect ha ha ha
do it again hey you [ __ ] there you
know should Leyden get a closer I don't
trust them
that's it perfect that's a perfect shot
that should do more than 40 sticks
forever
what's critical shot it only that's
forward I don't
he's so sexy look at this photo that was
beautiful ah crap
okay how did Portia I thought I would do
more I just keep on thinking photos I
guess
I need more damage on my camera I need
to upgrade it or something I definitely
miss yeah perfect take a picture of the
wall I mean it shouldn't take this long
to kill someone
one more two more probably yeah knew it
there you go I'm dead you're dead I mean
I'm alive it's one for funsies
okay now I really need to upgrade my
camera or something cuz I I think I am
this what is this
how do i okay
range sure yes then maybe one two blasts
yes
is it safe oh so that's what the points
are for you see really that
yeah is that yeah let's go back
shiny object faint the glowing crazy
star spinning arm let's get the [ __ ] out
of here
gonna do a same state got a damn ass I
use dates uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
strut that ass strut that ass strut that
strut that ass strut that hmm you what
at the Arsenal and you got a strut that
ass oh oh crap we gotta pass these
freakin ghost again I hate this girl
it's so creepy that's what I would do if
I were a girl huh I mean a zombie maybe
I don't know I would be a pretty good
zombie I think
I would be fine a shop
ah no no
what if I hadn't have saved say I would
have [ __ ] killed myself thank God for
seeing States what do you think about
doing the layers you gotta laugh as I
use AIDS I get the feeling I'm gonna
screw this again but we'll see
okay okay run run run run run run run
run run run run run
why any [ __ ] [ __ ] can run faster
than this if your life is at stake it's
like oh he's behind me no it's not funny
Maya it's not freaking funny if I do
replay hours of [ __ ] gameplay because
you you want it strut that ass strut
that what did I sing earlier when I went
on the skis there's skipping downstairs
skipping downstairs I have [ __ ]
[ __ ] foot skipping down the stairs
[Music]
look at this move look at this Mel look
at this mouth I'm working it working it
working it working it uh-huh
okay let's find our [ __ ] sister but
first working it uh-huh working it
uh-huh working it working it working it
uh-huh everyday I'm hustling oh that
that's better
every day you hustling every name uh-huh
anyway let's go let's go I poke what be
what oh case we have the diamond key
let's go save our sister let's go hey Oh
a thing gets in here I'm not sure it
could be that no it's not in there
it's actually here
all right where do we go where do we go
hey y'all ah crap crap crap crap come at
me bro
no shiny objects